rein in die pedale und rauf auf dem pop
up radweg diese neuen gelb markierten
fahrradstreifen haben in berlin einiges
in bewegung gebracht sie wurden eilig in
der korona pandemie geschaffen um
fahrradfahrern mehr platz und sicherheit
zu bieten
für die kästner ist das aber nicht genug
er träumt von einer innenstadt ganz ohne
privaten autoverkehr und sammelt
unterschriften für ein volksbegehren
wir wünschen uns auch dass die stadt
klimafreundlicher wird und die
klimaziele erreichen wir nicht wenn wir
weiterhin mit strom fahren und sogar mit
e autos erreichen wir nicht unsere ziele
der autos können auch unfälle bauen und
nehmen trotzdem viel platz weg sein ziel
genug unterschriften zusammenzubekommen
damit die berliner am tag der
bundestagswahl im september
auch darüber abstimmen ob sie autos aus
der innenstadt verbannen wollen und wie
sieht das die politik so einem termin
mit der berliner verkehrssenatorin bin
ich wieder auf einem neuen radweg
unterwegs 300 parkplätze für autos
wurden hier vor kurzem abgeschafft und
die grüne verkehrssenatorin will die
mobilitäts wende in berlin noch weiter
voranbringen
dass wir erst mal die angebote deutlich
ausweiten also mehr öpnv eine bessere
infrastruktur eine bessere
verkehrsinfrastruktur auch für die
fußgängerinnen und dass wir dann hier
wahrscheinlich auch den preis für den
öffentlichen raum verteilt 100 kilometer
schnell radwege sind geplant um die
berliner innenstadt demnächst besser mit
den außenbezirken zu verbinden
der mobilitäts forscher andreas knie
besitzt kein fahrrad und kein auto er
bucht bahnfahrten autos und fahrräder
mit dem handy und fordert eine radikale
strategie nur geteilte mobilität stoppe
den flächenverbrauch so sein credo wir
werden viel mehr mobile arbeit haben und
wir werden lernen auch in ländlichen
räumen die autos zu teilen
wird nicht so das klassische carsharing
sein sondern wenn man allein unterwegs
ist macht es keinen sinn wenn fünf
mensch mit fünf autos zur selben zeit in
dieselbe richtung fahren sondern fahren
eben fünf menschen in einem auto das
kann man mit digitalen plattform
wunderbar machen und so können wir auch
am land die zahl der autos drastisch
reduzieren
wie sind wir in zukunft unterwegs die
mobilitäts wende weg vom auto hat gerade
erst begonnen